chamonix les skieurs qui font la célèbre
vallée blanche vont désormais pouvoir se
servir du petit train rouge pour
redescendre dans la station le train de
montant versé son nom qui ne
fonctionnait que l'été circulent depuis
sept saisons l'hiver également pour la
plus grande joie des touristes en été
les rames se suivent les voyageurs se
bousculent au guichet s'empilent dans
les voitures ils sont plus de 10000 les
jours de pointe à bord du petit train à
crémaillère destination la mer de glace
désormais le chemin de fer du montenvers
propose ce voyage avec une autre
ambiance moins de monde et surtout la
neige qui transfigure le paysage alors à
s'ignorer
ça vous a plu c'est magnifique je n'ai
jamais vu un tel paysage c'est son
charme différents quoi un exceptionnel
mondial et tb je crois qu'ils versent
promologis
pour l'instant la société du chemin de
fer chamonix montenvers ne fait pas de
prévisions sur la fréquentation
hivernale de la ligne elle compte
surtout sur une clientèle familiale la
même qu'en été elle compte aussi sur les
80000 ce coeur qui descendent la vallée
blanche et qu'elle pourrait récupérer à
partir de son téléphérique qui fait la
liaison avec la mer de glace un billet
commun aiguille du midi montenvers est
désormais en vente
depuis 1907 date d'ouverture de la ligne
le personnel conducteur mécanicien
passer l'hiver dans les ateliers à
l'entretien du matériel
désormais il partagera son activité avec
le service roulant d'un autre côté les
travaux de déneigement pour la
réouverture de la ligne au printemps
seront quasiment supprimé puisque le
train va rouler en toute saison
on l'a fait un peu pour la vallée pour
la le prestige de chamonix aussi parce
que bon bah disons qu'on pousse est
tellement que et puis le problème c'est
quand celui-ci tombe
pourquoi nous en france on tournait pas
mais pour exploiter la ligne en hiver il
a fallu faire des investissements
énormes
à partir de 1965 des ouvrages par
avalanche ont été construits pendant les
deux saisons d'été 90-91 426 mètres de
couverture ont été réalisés il reste
encore 115 mètres à couvrir pour
sécuriser des petits couloirs
d'avalanche
c'est pourquoi cette année encore en
période à risque le petit train ne
circulera pas en été les rames se
suivent les voyageurs se bousculent au
guichet s'empilent dans les voitures ils
sont plus de 10000 les jours de pointe à
bord du petit train à crémaillère
destination la mer de glace
désormais le chemin de fer du montenvers
propose ce voyage avec une autre
ambiance moins de monde et surtout la
neige qui transfigure le paysage
alors signalé ça vous a plu c'est
magnifique je n'ai jamais vu un tel
paysage son charme différents quoi un
exceptionnel mondial était mais je crois
qu'ils versent promologis
pour l'instant la société du chemin de
fer chamonix montenvers ne fait pas de
prévisions sur la fréquentation
hivernale de la ligne elle compte
surtout sur une clientèle familiale la
même qu'en été elle compte aussi sur les
80000 ce coeur qui descendent la vallée
blanche et qu'elle pourrait récupérer à
partir de son téléphérique qui fait la
liaison avec la mer de glace un billet
commun aiguille du midi montenvers est
désormais en vente depuis 1907 date
d'ouverture de la ligne le personnel
conducteur mécanicien passer l'hiver
dans les ateliers à l'entretien du
matériel
désormais il partagera son activité avec
le service roulant
d'un autre côté les travaux de
déneigement pour la réouverture de la
ligne au printemps seront quasiment
supprimé puisque le train va rouler en
toute saison
on l'a fait un peu pour la vallée pour
la le prestige de chameliers aussi parce
que bon mais disons qu'on nous poussait
tellement que et puis le problème c'est
quand celui-ci tourne
pourquoi nous en france on tournait pas
mais pour exploiter la ligne en hiver il
a fallu faire des investissements
énormes
à partir de 1965 des ouvrages par
avalanche ont été construits pendant les
deux saisons d'été 90-91 426 mètres de
couverture ont été réalisés il reste
encore 115 mètres à couvrir pour
sécuriser des petits couloirs
d'avalanche
c'est pourquoi cette année encore en
période à risque le petit train ne
circulera pas